judging by election results across the
country last night this could be a very
tough fall for Republicans the incumbent
party typically gets hurt in the first
midterm almost always and this year
could be worse than usual for a bunch of
different reasons but one of those
reasons may be the Republicans are
running on entirely the wrong issues
your average Republican officeholders
seems to believe that most Americans
love mass immigration they say that all
the time turns out is not true big
Republican donors love mass immigration
sort of professional Democrats it
increases the size of their party but
normal people are very skeptical with it
actually consider a new CBS YouGov poll
it's amazing turns out far more
Americans think immigration is making
their communities worse not better and
it's not just those dreaded white people
Democrats are always attacking who think
that 45% of African Americans say
immigration is hurting them only 17% say
is helping how about Hispanics were they
on this Republican consultants tell you
and they tell their candidates never to
say a negative word about immigration
for fear of alienating Hispanic voters
who are supposedly very sensitive on the
subject turns out that's idiotic and
patronizing actually 44% of Hispanic
voters say immigration is hurting their
communities just 28% say it's improving
things the numbers could not be clearer
immigration is a powerful issue for
Americans of all kinds and it's an issue
that Republicans can win on if only they
were brave enough to listen to voters
but they're not after a year and a half
of total control of Congress no wall is
being built sanctuary cities remain
well-funded
you verify is not enacted chain
migration is alive and well nothing is
happening another media are telling you
it's immoral somehow to separate the
illegal immigrant parents from their
children lots of Republicans agree with
this but wait Americans who get arrested
are separated from their children
American citizens should be treated more
harshly than illegal aliens how is that
here's the Attorney General on the
subject watch this we believe every
person that enters the country illegally
like that should be prosecuted and you
can't be given immunity the people who
are bring children with them recklessly
and improper
illegally we don't want to do this at
all if people don't want to be separated
from their children they should not
bring them with them so you hear Jeff
Sessions criticized a lot for a bunch of
different things but when you come right
down to it on this issue he's basically
the only person in Washington still
arguing that borders and laws matter
maybe the rest of his party will wake up
and realize they do Lou Dobbs host Lou
Dobbs tonight on Fox Business and he
joins us tonight well it's great to see
you you thought about this issue more
deeply than almost anybody I know does
it surprise you that no one has paused
to ask what wait a second if it's wrong
for illegal aliens to be separated from
their kids when they commit a crime why
is it not wrong for American citizens to
be separated from their kids when they
commit a crime because there are
protected groups in the United States
but in when it comes to illegal
immigrants they are a preferred group it
is and it is so because the the
establishment the Business Roundtable
the Chamber of Commerce US
multinationals want cheaper labor they
want open borders they want to quote
unquote harmonize those borders you
don't hear much about the the North
American Union anymore but under George
Bush and in through the most of the
Obama administration the North American
Union that is bringing a Canada and
Mexico together with the United States
was their ultimate goal
yes had to back off because of the
numbers that you just showed in that
poll because the reality is Americans
understand what's happening whatever the
race whatever the sex whatever the
socio-economic dicing you want to do
with the numbers Americans know when
they're being lied to and they can feel
the reality and the reality is that we
don't have borders because we in the
last month just returned to the highest
levels of illegal immigration across our
southern border what's so interesting
when you look at these numbers is that
Democrats will tell you in the media
tells you a lot of Republicans tell you
that people don't like immigration
because they're racist because they're
big negative numbers less than 20% of
African Americans say immigration has
made their communities better they're
not for it Hispanic Americans same thing
so
it's not really about bigotry actually
because this cuts across races or
absolutely and of course the the entire
left-wing and establishment argument
collapses if people look at the reality
the reality is that all of those
ethnocentric interest groups and
activist groups are basically spewing
propaganda and they have it's all been
picked up at the national left-wing
media supported by the establishment and
corporate America I to the to obviously
that the detriment of working men and
women particularly at the lowest paying
levels lowest skilled levels lowest
education levels in this country because
the people crossing that border is the
president has made clear throughout our
not the coming across on the basis of
merit they're coming across on the basis
of Mexican government policy which
insists that they be transferred to the
United States except for the least
advantaged amongst their society that is
to you know you've been saying this for
twenty years and I remember vividly when
we worked at another network and you
said things like that and people laughed
at you and it turned out you were right
you were completely right I mean it was
frustrating it must rate you well they
still laugh a little bit I hope because
it we should have a sense of humor about
the reality that is American politics we
just elected a president in 2016 who was
talking about each of these issues and
the idiot establishment are telling the
rhinos in the Republican Party they
should run on tax cuts instead of on
trade on jobs on markets that are
improving and and the issue of illegal
immigration that's right
that's what security lou dobbs thank you
for that it's great to see you great to
be with events